This is a pie chart.
And this is Scottish political
economist William Playfair,
who created the world's
first pie chart,
along with some of the first
line and bar charts.
Data visualisation
is everywhere today,
but when Playfair first created them
over 200 years ago,
using shapes to represent numbers
was largely sneered at.
How could drawings truly
represent solid scientific data?
But now data visualisation
has become an art form of its own.
Here are five charts that have,
in their own way, changed the world.
One of the best known uses
of data visualisation
was devised in London in 1854.
At the time, it was widely believed
that infectious diseases like
cholera were spread through the air.
Surgeon John Snow felt differently.
He was convinced that infections
could be spread by dirty water.
And when a deadly outbreak
of cholera occurred in Soho,
Snow tracked each case and
marked them with a dot on a map.
A clear picture emerged.
All the deaths from cholera
were clustered around a water pump
on Broad Street.
When he presented his findings
to the local officials,
the pump was shut down
and the outbreak ended.
Dr John Snow fundamentally changed
our understanding of microbes,
and his simple dot maps
were a huge part of that.
Around about the same time,
"the lady with the lamp",
Florence Nightingale,
used a cunning visual
to save even more lives.
During the Crimean War,
she realised that unsanitary
conditions in hospitals
were killing more soldiers than were
dying on the battlefield itself.
She wanted to persuade
Queen Victoria,
head of the British Army
at the time,
to fund better conditions
in military hospitals.
So she created the Coxcomb,
a sort of uneven pie chart
which showcased the data
on the causes of soldiers' deaths
in a highly effective way.
Her efforts had sweeping impact,
not only improving
the sanitary conditions
of army hospitals at the time,
but ultimately changing
the face of modern healthcare.
One of the most original examples
of data visualisation
was created by American historian
and civil rights activist
W.E.B Du Bois
for the 1900 Paris World's Fair.
He presented a series
of hand-made charts
showcasing the educational,
social and business accomplishments
of black Americans in the 35 years
since slavery had been
officially abolished.
The materials both challenged
stereotypes
and illustrated
how black communities
were still being discriminated
against.
Du Bois hoped the visualisations
would help to end racial prejudice
in the world.
"The problem of the 20th century
"is the problem of the color-line,"
he wrote.
Although his dreams weren't
realised, Du Bois' beautiful charts
are now recognised as
a powerful use of data visualisation
to demonstrate social change.
Data visualisation can also
be used for misinformation,
sometimes
with disastrous consequences.
This is the Kallikak family tree.
As a chart,
it's not ground-breaking,
but its impact was profound.
It was conjured up by Henry Goddard,
an American psychologist
and eugenicist
who believed that one
of society's greatest problems
was "feeble-minded" people -
basically, anyone deemed
to be of lower intelligence.
Goddard wrote a book based
on the story of Martin Kallikak,
a soldier who was married
and had a family
of fine, upstanding citizens.
But according to the book,
Martin Kallikak
had a one-night stand
with a "feeble-minded" barmaid.
She had a son who became
known as "Old Horror",
who went on to father ten children.
According to Goddard,
feeble-mindedness was hereditary,
and the family was full
of what he called
"the lowest types of human beings".
But it was a fiction.
The barmaid never existed.
Even so, the Kallikak family tree
could be found in school textbooks
as late as the 1950s, and it was
also used by the eugenics movement
for decades afterwards.
And it was adopted by the Nazis,
who used it in propaganda films
to gain support
for their racial purity laws,
which led to the murder of thousands
of disabled people in the Holocaust.
Sometimes, iconic status
can be achieved almost accidentally.
In 2018, scientist Ed Hawkins
was invited to give a speech
about climate change at Hay,
a literary festival in Wales.
He needed to convey the increase
in global average temperatures
to a largely
non-scientific audience.
So, he devised a chart
that used no words, just colours.
It was a stunningly simple way
of demonstrating how the planet
had warmed since 1850.
The chart, known
as the warming stripes,
uses blues to indicate
cooler than average years
and reds to show years with
temperatures hotter than average.
Updated every year,
Hawkins says 2022 was the first year
that every country
needed a new red stripe,
demonstrating how fast
the Earth's climate is changing.
Although the graphic breaks some
of the rules of data visualisation -
it doesn't provide
a title or legend -
arguably, it is one of the most
iconic graphics of modern times.
What do you think the next chart
to change the world will be?